hi I'm Erik Bosse and adventures 4 has a
lot of questions to answer after
Avengers infinity war close to the top
of that list is what role Captain
America play in this end game against
Thanos why did he have a relatively
smaller role to play in infinity war
after directing them in Winter Soldier
in Civil War why did the Russo brothers
bench the old man in this one I didn't
think that shot could get any sadder
let's look at some recent unearthed
clues from infinity war and some
interesting statements from the
directors screenwriters and other cast
members to theorize what caps Avengers 4
mission could be okay after Infinity
Ward came out the filmmakers
acknowledged that Captain America had
more of a supporting role in the fight
against Thanos compared to the other
Avengers and actually they revealed that
an alternate ending of the script
originally planned for Kats world to be
even smaller the original plan was to
remove cap from the story altogether to
keep him an absent fugitive figure on
the run following his departure after
Civil War the Russo said they intended
on cap and Starks division being the
core reason for the Avengers loss
against Thanos cap wasn't even gonna
join the fight until the last minute
remember a Thor's epic mid-battle return
with Stormbreaker that you found herself
standing and applauding at with a
stranger named Randy who is now seen you
cry that twist was originally going to
be Captain America finally joining the
fight but according to the Russos
everyone at Marvel lost their minds that
the idea of cap coming in so late to the
movie so they revised the story so that
he arrives earlier to save vision and
Edinboro still you have to admit
compared to say Santos or Doctor Strange
Kats decisions carry a bit less weight
in the overall story but the
screenwriters said that there was a good
reason for that some characters had have
great stories in the second movie
somebody like cap or Natasha you might
feel oh they didn't have quite as much
to do as say Thor or Doctor Strange and
that surprises me it's likely because
they have a lot to do in the next one
McFeely has actually gone on to describe
caps journey in Avengers 4 as a very
intense arc
very intense so assuming Avengers 4
becomes more of CAP story
what will that very intense arc be well
recently while rewatched infinity war
the 14 million time this interesting
detail came up the flip phone that Tony
and cap exchange is a way to communicate
with each other at the end of civil war
early in the movie Tony whips out that
flip phone and we see a close-up of the
screen showing Steve Rogers number now
you're wondering that phone number is an
Atlanta area code given to production by
Disney probably since they shot the
movie in Atlanta and if you try to call
it nothing happens even though the
directors wanted to record a voice
message from Steve Rogers Disney nixed
the idea anyway the new detail
discovered by a guy on reddit who uses
the same kind of flip phone is this
envelope icon when it looks like that it
means you have an unopened text message
so apparently Tony Stark has an unread
text from cap who is the only person who
has the number to this burner phone and
later in a sequence when banner finds
the phone and uses it to call Steve
there's another icon these arrows which
means the phone is sending or receiving
some file the icon shows up after you
accept receiving an incoming file or
after you've sent a really low quality
photo from your handy 2011 AT&T Z 221 so
what could those secret correspondences
between cap and Tony be well my guess is
the unopened text is cap updating Tony
on his last location after they've moved
on or perhaps some news about the
general sense of concern that vision had
been feeling from the mind stone most
likely warning him about Thanos it's
coming arrival and maybe Tony just
doesn't want to open it because he would
prefer to have some plausible
deniability on caps whereabouts still
Tony must care a little about cap after
all he did keep that flip phone on him
while jogging with pepper and it was
fully charged and then when it comes to
that sent or received file I think was
Tony sending cap an image of ebony maw
and call obsidian that he took or maybe
showing their cue ship all to warn cap
about this new emergency in New York the
point is this flip phone means that cap
and Tony are still in communication
regardless of how archaic and papercut
connected by yarn the means may be and
despite not once appearing together on
screen infinity war their path to
defeating Thanos may be tied to some
link to their past selves perhaps
something rooted in the year 2011 and
look out because I'm about to get into
some possible spoilers for Avengers 4 so
when it comes to Avengers 4 I don't
think it's that crazy to assume caps
very intense arc might take him into the
past yeah I'm talking about time travel
people the evidence is everywhere there
were these set photos of Chris Evans
looking clean shaven and spiffy wearing
his 2011-2012 era Captain America suit
the same one that he wore in the Battle
of New York in the first Avengers his
suit has definitely changed in the years
since then there was an Instagram post
from Frank Grillo
the actor who played Brock aka
crossbones and Winter Soldier in Civil
War he hash teased that he might return
and Avengers 4 which is a little weird
because we definitely saw him blow up in
Civil War plus just recently in the
post-credits scene of ant-man in the
wasp we definitely heard the term time
vortex mentioned as a danger the quantum
realm and don't get sucked into a time
vortex and that movie's director Peyton
Reed repeated the term time vortex and
confirmed we shouldn't rule out time
travel as the possibility furthermore
Margo had Kevin Feige himself has said
Avengers 4 story draws inspiration from
the finale episode of Star Trek The Next
Generation that episode is titled all
good things and it features Picard
jumping through time leading three
versions of his crew in the past present
and future to save humanity also wasp
actor Evangeline Lilly compared Avengers
4 to her experience shooting lost season
4 in that season the series begins to
include flash forwards a future timeline
concurrent with the present timeline on
the island and it opened up the show to
multiple time periods where in the
season finale heading into season 5 the
island literally becomes unstuck in time
causing the characters to jump around
two different years within the timeline
it's intense very intense this could
describe Kats very intense arc and
Avengers 4 just imagine a scenario in
which Tony Stark realizes that his
present-day relationship with cap is
just too fraught too damaged by their
battles and Civil War and that by
comparison their friendship back in the
good old days in 2012 the heyday of the
AT&T is e220 flip-phone was invulnerable
they were tight you're filled with
schwarmann they're ready to avenge
anything and that aid school cap is the
cap that Tony needs the cap who proudly
wore the Stars and Stripes and gave him
that sick assist in Manhattan the cap
who beat the piss out of Brock and as
other crooked shield goons in an
elevator the cap in Avengers 4 might
just follow in the footsteps of another
famous cab cat the card in all good
things in a barrier Trent's Ark that
slips back and forth through time to the
moments he felt the most heroic to
inspire him to be a hero once more but
if this theory is true here's a question
I'll leave you with which MCU moments
from movies past would you most want to
see restage and Avengers for comment
down below with your thoughts and follow
me on Twitter and Instagram
Grandaddy a boss to keep track of me me
me me me and some fun stuff that I'm
really excited about that I'm working on
like this video shared around and
subscribe to new rock stars for more
Avengers for predictin guys there's only
253 days left until the premiere which
you know by my math means we can fit in
about twenty four hundred more
screenings and infinity war there's so
many clues Carn everyone let's get to
rewatching who needs friends